aujourd'hui vendredi 12 décembre
bienvenue sur tvfils 78% ce nouveau
journal de la rédaction aujourd'hui dans
l'actualité l'État islamique qui
poursuit sa progression en Irak les
chrétiens contraints à l'exil une
famille de 8 personnes vient d'être
accueillies à Saint-Cyr l'école nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre les fêtes
de fin d'année qui approche nous verrons
comment se prépare les Français pour
leur repas malgré la crise et puis nous
parlerons aussi du marché de Noël de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec un autre
invité organisateur de l'événement et
puis l'essentiel de la semaine hausse
des dons en faveur du Téléthon 70ème
anniversaire des CRS célébrés à
Versailles et témoignages de la mère
d'une victime de Mohamed Merah
aujourd'hui engagé contre l'extrémisme
une information économique pour débuter
le groupe PSA Peugeot Citroën qui vient
d'annoncer son intention d'investir 153
millions d'euros dans son usine de
Poissy au cours des deux prochaines
années après l'annonce de la création
d'une équipe de nuit sur le site de
Renault Flins fin novembre c'est une
deuxième bonne nouvelle pour le secteur
de l'automobile dans les Yvelines le
premier département automobile de France
avec 45 000 salariés et 150 entreprises
on ira que la situation pour les
chrétiens ne s'arrangent toujours pas
persécuté par l'État islamique les
pratiquants sont obligés de fuir le pays
hier jeudi c'est une famille de huit
personnes originaires d'un village près
de moussoul et qui a trouvé refuge dans
la ville de Saint-Cyr-l'École un
reportage de Williams
mais exténuées que cette famille
iraquienne de confessions chrétiennes a
rejoint ce jeudi la mairie de
Saint-Cyr-l'École la ville s'était
portée candidate pour recevoir des
réfugiés et leur fournir ainsi un
logement de 80 mètres carrés pour Bachar
perd de trois enfants c'est une
délivrance
nous avons du fuir par le nord et
dormira même le sol dans des bâtiments
sans porte ni fenêtres c'est une amie de
ma sœur qui habite Paris qui a réussi à
faire les démarches au consulat français
pour nous aider à nous réfugier en
France
c'était l'enfer et aujourd'hui c'est le
paradis à Mossoul tout le monde aimerait
être à notre place c'est 8 personnes
étaient hébergées depuis novembre à
Courbevoie dans un logement de 15 mètres
carrés une situation jugée insoutenable
pour Anne-Claude rançon présidente de
l'association et le terreau se pour le
droit des chrétiens nous on a été alerté
par un problème de santé pour le bébé et
il fallait agir en urgence et pour qu'on
appelait SAMU donc il a fallu s'occuper
d'abord du bébé ensuite ramener la
famille dans son lieu de d'habitation et
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert la
situation
d'habitation difficile en 48 heures
toutes les associations ont mis en
oeuvre les moyens nécessaires pour le
réserver un accueil des plus chaleureux
la Croix-Rouge le Secours Catholique les
Restos du coeur on a tout mobilisé pour
être capable de les accueillir pour eux
on va mobiliser les services pour que
d'abord ils apprennent rapidement le
français et puis qui s'intègre dans
notre pays et qu'on trouve du travail à
ceux qui peuvent travailler
à te rejoindre son nouveau logement dans
les Yvelines d'autres villes comme La
Celle-Saint-Cloud ont également
accueilli des réfugiés irakiens
l'invité de ce vendredi à présent Michel
Cyprien référent événementiel du centre
Alfred de Vigny à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
bonjour et bienvenue ce week-end nouvel
édition du Marché de Noël 10h 18h au
gymnase des pyramides on va en parler
avec vous juste le temps aussi de
présenter et Green du Rupt bienvenue
vous n'êtes pas associé au marché de
Noël mais vous avez aussi une actualité
qui est liée à voisin le bretonneuse
c'est cette rencontre de football dans
le cadre de la Coupe de France des
féminines on va en parler dans un
instant parce que vous avez deux
casquettes c'est pour ça que vous êtes
venus accompagner on va garder ça pour
la seconde partie de l'entretien on va
tout d'abord parler de ce marché de Noël
à Voisins le bretonneux combien
d'exposants attendus combien de
visiteurs cette année un exposant en est
limité à la taille du gymnase donc c'est
ou 96 ou 97 sur les dispositions au
niveau sécurité cette année c'est 96
donc
de visiteurs bah on espère 10 15000
c'est fonction du temps donc la météo a
l'air d'être à peu près bonne ce weekend
par rapport à ce qu'on vient de vivre
cette semaine donc voilà on croise les
doigts s'il fait beau les gens sortent
ce qui fait du marché les voisins de
Noël de Voisins-le-Bretonneux l'un des
plus importants dans le département nous
sommes le deuxième des Yvelines en
nombre d'exposants et des choses
l'agglomération Montigny-le-Bretonneux
la semaine dernière justement vous vous
accordez sur les dates pour pas que ça
se chevauche entre les différentes
communes il y a de plus en plus de
marché de Noël donc voilà le plus
difficile c'est trouver des dates
disponibles bon en général
nous traditionnellement c'est le
week-end avant les vacances de Noël donc
Montigny c'est connait nos dates et nous
on connaît les leurs donc ils essaient
de faire la semaine d'avant chacun fait
de son côté en principe ça se passe bien
si tu arrives une année qu'on soit en
même temps mais à priori ça pas été
préjudiciable mais Alain ni à l'autre
donc il y a il y a un potentiel client
je veux dire qui est fidèle donc ça
c'est un système de Noël ils sont
effectivement assez nombreux à s'y
rendre chaque année l'idée c'est à la
fois de trouver des cadeaux il y a des
artisans qui sont présents de trouver de
quoi manger aussi comment vous faites un
petit peu la sélection l'équilibre le
mélange comment ça se passe quelle est
la recette pour un bon marché de Noël
bah la recette c'est d'essayer de tous
les ans de surprendre les visiteurs avec
des choses nouvelles c'est ça le plus
difficile
sachant que on est beaucoup sollicité
pour les gens qui créent des bijoux
enfin tout insta de création céramique
en porcelaine etc et que nous avons un
comité de sélection nous sommes trois et
on travaille sur deux avec pressebook
photo enfin bon si on a des doutes on
appelle les gens etc
tout à fait son présent tout à fait et
on essaie de limiter par catégorie bon
bijoux essaie qui en est 10 11 12
maximum après les articles en textils
enfin on se rend compte qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui qui sont qu'on a
esprit créatif et qui fabriquent des
choses nouvelles tous les ans et qui
nous étonnent même des fois l'exposant
viennent de France de la France entière
on a le dernier exposant qu'on a eu
suite à des estomons là c'est quelqu'un
qui habite à voisins qui se déclaé
auto-entrepreneur cette année et qui est
quelqu'un du Sud et qui qui vante les
produits du Sud quoi qui est bon bah
c'est on trouve ça super sympa quoi je
veux dire donc une rotation entre les
différents artisans qui viennent
justement vous voilà chaque année
difficile c'est d'envoyer une lettre à
des gens qui sont venus une fois deux
fois leur expliquer que pour cette année
on va pas les prendre pour les raisons
que je vais expliquer au début de
l'interview c'est que on essaye d'en
nouvelle à 30 40% tous les ans ce qui
est pas c'est pas le plus facile les
seuls qui sont vraiment fidèles je
dirais c'est les viticulteurs les
producteurs
c'est uniquement sur book où est-ce que
vous faites le déplacement ou est-ce
qu'ils viennent vous faire tester les
produits aussi bah disons que là quand
on a des nouveaux c'est un voir deux et
on essaye ça c'est un petit peu notre
déontologie de pas faire de concurrence
si on a un bordelais bon on a la chance
le Bordelais très très vaste il y a les
médocs il y a écrit bourgeois etc on
essaye de voir un ou deux Bordeaux mais
pas plus Bourgogne il y en a qu'un
champagne vous êtes plutôt bien guidé
j'imagine avec votre centre d'œnologie
qui a été distinguée dans les derniers
jours avec Pascal piedmar qui a gagné la
Coupe de France avec ses équipes
c'est lui qui fait la sélection
viticulteur il y a un coup de cœur cette
année un exposant particulier c'est
difficile pour les autres mais il y a
quelque chose qui sera qui va souffleur
de verre cette année donc il fait des
choses vraiment de qualité on en a pas
tous les ans donc on est content on est
content de l'avoir quoi il y a une forte
ça coûte cher un emplacement pour
s'installer non je peux dire le prix il
y a pas de honte c'est 43 € le mètre
linéaire pour le weekend et les
exposants s'y retrouve en général assez
bien voilà la moyenne c'est 3 mètres
la surface est environ 300 mètres on a
96 exposants et ça fait une moyenne de 3
mètres linéaire au sol à peu près par
exposant aujourd'hui la situation
économique est plutôt compliquée on le
voit les gens font les courses même en
avance par rapport à Noël vous ne
craignez pas pour le marché de Noël
cette année non parce que les gens sont
fidèles et l'attendent même ils viennent
par curiosité parce qu'ils savent qu'on
renouvelle à 35 40% les exposants ils
vont ils viennent voir qu'est-ce qu'il
va y avoir de nouveau cette année quoi
aussi aussi alors on va en parler ce
sera juste après ce micro-trottoir
qu'attendez-vous d'un marché de Noël
justement vos réponses
un peu de tout la déco tout déjà et puis
les trucs du terroir tout ça quoi à
manger surtout tout ce qu'il y a de loin
à manger des bonnes choses et puis une
bonne ambiance une bonne décoration bah
tout ce qui est artisanale surtout Dijon
pour Noël
Strasbourg et je trouve que tous les
marchés qui en découlent sont de pas le
imitation des nouveautés déjà pas
toujours la même chose
du vin chaud ça va nous réchauffer un
peu pour
le petit courant d'air qu'on trouve à
actuellement
le vin chaud il y en aura oui on a
surtout un bar à soupe qui fait vraiment
un bon carton tous les ans il y en a
jamais assez ça a consommé sans
modération donc c'est très bien vous
pouvez le dire c'est pas de souci je le
disais juste avant le micro-trottoir il
y aura du football également parce que
parallèlement le dimanche sur le terrain
juste à côté du gymnase des pyramides où
se déroule le marché de Noël il aura
cette rencontre de football féminin du
voisin Football Club vous en vous en
occupez également c'est un club tout
récent voilà nous sommes
on s'est créé le 1er septembre 2013 donc
on est parti en bas de l'échelle avec un
défi qu'on connaissait parce que nous
avons sévi avec le coach actuel qui est
Wilfried des roches j'aurais vraiment le
citer moi je suis dirigeant je suis un
peu le DRH je dirais du groupe et nous
avons été entraîneur dans une autre
équipe et on est parti bon pour des
raisons personnelles et quand on a voulu
créer cette équipe de football à Voisins
le président était vraiment Stéphane
legrier qui est le président qui a pas
pu venir aujourd'hui mais bon là je
voulais le citer aussi son grand reste
est créé une équipe féminine donc les
filles sachant qu'on voulait faire ça au
voisin nous ont pratiquement tous
rejoint justement quel était quel était
votre motivation vous Evelyne pour
arriver sur ce club de voisin de
Bretonneux quand une équipe toute jeune
se crée comme ça
moi donc j'étais parti du club avant où
était Michel et Wilfried pour aller
jouer dans un autre club et les filles
m'ont parlé justement de la motivation
de Wilfried et Michel de monter une
équipe féminine et donc bah comme
j'avais bien aimé jouer à leur côté je
les ai suivis Voisins-le-Bretonneux
est-ce que les résultats suivent oui
parce que une année vous avez déjà connu
une montée tout à fait on est monté dès
la première année cette année en PH où
on joue encore contre notre concurrent
Poissy direct cette année pour la montée
en DHR donc au bout de l'année de monter
en deux ans c'était l'objectif c'était
l'objectif et
ce qui fait que ça marche aussi bien
c'est quoi c'est l'émulation de de la
création de la jeunesse de cette équipe
tout d'abord oui la jeunesse de notre
équipe je pense que les coachs aussi
nous poussent pas mal et nous
connaissent aussi pas mal dans nos
qualités nos défauts de chacune et puis
c'est vrai qu'on a une très bonne
cohésion d'équipe au sein du voisin
Football Club j'ai pas précisé votre
poste vous êtes milieu défensive
également
sur les sur les postes de chacune même
si c'est une équipe ou tout se passe
bien on va pas faire de mauvaises en 30
ce soir quand même il y a une section
féminine qui est lancé à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux elle évolue en
championnat elle évolue évolue aussi en
Coupe de France sur un match donc ce
weekend on le disait ce sera Bourges
pour le contre du compte du quatrième
tour fédéral c'est ça à 14h30 c'est un
match qui sera difficile de division au
dessus pour
nous donc ça sera en mode
pour nous certes ça sera un match
difficile bah qu'on a essayé de pas mal
préparer quand même après je pense que
notre force c'est notre collectif et
notre entente notre solidarité surtout
c'est le type de match qu'on aime bien
qu'on aime bien faire où on est souvent
solide et solidaire et souvent les
résultats suivent derrière il y a un
enjeu derrière si vous passez ce tour là
ce sera ensuite au niveau national parce
que là ça reste pour l'instant fédéral
c'est le Tour National premier tour
nationale c'est le premier tour national
c'était l'objectif qui avait été fixé ou
c'est que du bonus là le pour nous la
Coupe de France c'est le bonus on était
surtout basé sur le championnat et sur
la montée cette année après pour nous
bah c'est une grande première de pouvoir
être entouré donc national donc on
espère pourquoi pas le continuer avec la
rentrée des D1 au prochain tour n'ayez
pas peur de perdre trop de force avec ce
match de coupe par rapport au
championnat non bah non parce qu'après
C'est la trêve donc du coup on aura le
temps de se reposer et de
reprendre notre activité début janvier
et de se repencher directement sur le
championnat que vous habitiez voisin ou
non il faut venir soutenir cette équipe
il y a le marché de Noël et puis juste à
côté la rencontre dimanche un mot pour
conclure pour venir encourager votre
équipe pour conclure moi je suis partagé
en deux ce week-end samedi j'ai plus sur
le marché dimanche plus avec les filles
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour le journal de ce vendredi
on va revenir sur Noël à présent avec
cette étude européenne qui évoque pour
cette année une réduction de budget pour
les ménages français 518 euros c'est ce
que nous dépensons en moyenne c'est 4,5%
de moins que l'année dernière sortie
loisir cadeau sont impactés mais aussi
nourriture comme on réagissent les
professionnels et les moments de réponse
à vos anciens Bretonneux justement
autrefois préserver des aléas le budget
des Français pour le repas du réveillon
de Noël étant régression différents
sondages estiment la dépense moyenne par
personne à 168 euros c'est 3% de moins
que l'an passé alors dans les petits
commerces sont mises sur la diversité
des produits pour séduire les clients
comme se boucher un voisin le Bretonneux
qui n'a pas que le traditionnel chapon
sur son étal on a toujours là madame
fermière les poulardes
la pintade de Chaponnay qui est un petit
peu moins connue et puis mon loi et le
gibier c'est un chiffre d'affaires qui
normalement multiplié par deux donc par
rapport à moi normal donc faut pas faut
pas se louper
ce commerce vient d'ouvrir ses portes en
septembre dernier impossible d'estimer
les recettes mais signe encourageant les
commandes commencent déjà à arriver je
sais très bien que ça va arriver
beaucoup ce week-end parce que bon les
gens
privilégiés d'abord les cadeaux de Noël
on va faire très classique foie gras des
huîtres
probablement un soin canard en famille
canette ou quelque chose aux trois
fruits il y aura des pommes ils avaient
déjà commencé à passer commande tout ça
ou pas encore
avant d'acheter les clients font donc du
repérage chez le cas également dans
cette poissonnerie située quelques
mètres plus loin déjà ils font des
petits tests donc qui viennent ils
prennent un petit plateau ils font des
petits panachés avec les huîtres les
crevettes ils essayent pour aller
kaliser pas pour pouvoir faire leur
choix pour pour Noël pour faire un
peuple un beau plateau et puis régaler
leur convive quatre Français sur 10
auraient déjà testé leur repas de Noël
histoire malgré la crise de ne surtout
pas rater ce rendez-vous et si vous
manquez d'idées pourquoi ne pas faire
dans l'originalité ça va être tout
simple
le fameux cassoulet de Noël dans
l'actualité également ils étaient réunis
hier à la soufflerie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux l'équipe de
France de cyclisme sur piste et le
président de la FFC davidlaration ont
inauguré hier un tout nouvel équipement
pour améliorer leur performance il
s'agit d'un banc aerocycle l'outil va
leur permettre de travailler
l'aérodynamique à deux pas du tout
nouveau vélodrome des conditions optimum
on a atteint ça depuis pas mal d'années
moi ça fait au moins 10 ans que
j'attends ça donc maintenant d'avoir ça
juste auprès du Vélodrome à 2 km de
notre lieu d'entraînement c'est parfait
on perd pas de temps
dans les dans les transports et puis on
peut être tout de suite en contact avec
avec les ingénieurs donc c'est parfait
dans un instant l'essentiel de la
semaine mais tout d'abord elles peuvent
rapidement nous empoisonner la vie ce
sont les fuites de la Lyonnaise des Eaux
vient de lancer l'Aqua 360 une sorte de
tour de contrôle des systèmes
d'approvisionnement de l'eau pour
vérifier en temps réel que l'eau circule
normalement l'application est
actuellement en phase de test comme un
pu le constater notre équipe sur place à
l'usine de production d'eau potable de
Louveciennes qui dessert une partie des
communes de 50 ans en Yvelines
tout d'abord ça sert à avoir une vision
comme son lit de 360 donc
panoramique sur l'ensemble du système de
la ressource jusqu'au robinet des
usagers en passant par l'usine pour
l'instant il est en test et donc la
démonstration le montre maintenant il va
être mis entre les exploitants on
pourrait être 2015
seconde partie de ce journal et on passe
comme chaque vendredi à l'essentiel de
la semaine et un très bon bilan pour le
Téléthon l'édition 2014 permet de
renouer avec une hausse des tons plus de
82 millions d'euros de promesses
enregistrées au niveau national nous
sommes à laquelle il faudra ajouter
l'argent collecté sur le terrain par les
bénévoles et là aussi tous ces biens
passé comme nous l'expliquait lundi le
coordinateur départemental des Yvelines
attendez un petit peu à quelque chose de
fin je vais dire des séminaires une très
bonne mobilisation mais à ce point non
en effet surpris quand même parce que
bon c'est vrai qu'on a eu beaucoup de
nouvelles manifestations mais on
s'attendait pas une mobilisation sur le
terrain aussi importantes donc la
mobilisation du terrain veut dire est un
très grandes mobilisation que le
compteur est bien sera au dessus de
l'année dernière et puis un autre
chiffre est venu lundi de Coignières
97,90 c'est le pourcentage d'habitants
qui s'oppose à un élargissement de leur
communauté de communes la mairie a mené
un référendum face au projet de l'état
de créer des super agglomérations le
maire de Coignières qui s'oppose
fermement à un retour au sein de la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines qu'il avait quitté lors de
l'émergence des villes nouvelles
dans l'actualité cette semaine également
le 70e anniversaire de la Compagnie
républicaine de sécurité les CRS lundi
Bernard Cazeneuve le ministre de
l'Intérieur a fait le déplacement à
Versailles Mélanie poquet Patrick
Jacques de dix mais dont assisté à la
cérémonie
uniforme impeccable garde à vous et
ainsi sigle CRS pour Compagnie
républicaine de sécurité créé il y a
tout juste 70 ans le 8 décembre 1944 par
le général de Gaulle et c'est le château
de Versailles qui a été choisi pour
célébrer cette anniversaire un cadre qui
ne doit rien au hasard c'est à
Versailles en effet que la République
accueille ces hôtes de marque c'est donc
Mesdames Messieurs à bon droit que les
CRS reçurent ici même
leur drapeau en 1953
nageur sauveteur compagnie autoroutière
ou encore section de montagne les CRS
sont spécialisés dans le maintien de
l'ordre le ministre ainsi profité de son
discours pour interpeller les forces de
l'ordre avec dans sa ligne de mire la
mort de Rémi fresh militant contre le
barrage de Sivens dans le Tarn je vous
demande donc de participer pleinement
à la réflexion sur l'emploi de la force
que j'ai voulu engager à la suite du
drame de Sivens
je vous encourage à poursuivre dans
l'effort de modernisation
à vous doter des équipements et des
matériels spécialisés les mieux adaptés
pour bénéficier d'une ensemble d'une
vision d'ensemble des lieux au cours des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre les
plus délicates et également pour mieux
vous protéger
le ministre a ainsi annoncé en
renforcement dans les rangs des CRS
après la suppression de 2600 postes en
2012 ainsi je veux vous annoncer que 92
jeunes gardiens de la paix vont
rejoindre vos rang ce mois de décembre
et vos unités seront à nouveau dotées
d'agents supplémentaires en 2015 j'en
prends devant vous l'engagement
civil et non militaire les CRS sont
rassemblés en plus de 60 compagnies en
France dans les Yvelines la compagnie se
situe à Vélizy
justice morte c'était le mot d'ordre de
toute une profession mercredi 156
barreaux de français d'outre-mer on
défilé avec les autres professions
juridiques réglementées sur Paris pour
dénoncer le projet de loi Macron 50000
professionnels du droit unis pour nous
expliquer cette situation le bâtonnier
de Versailles Frédéric Landon extrait
d'une interview à retrouver en
intégralité sur notre site internet dès
à présent
c'est qu'on est en totale opposition
avec le projet Macron donc nous ne
connaissons pas précisément le contenu
il va y avoir une mobilisation
fantastique demain puisque pour la
reversailles environ 200 avocats vont
partir à Paris pour manifester avec
l'ensemble de leurs confrères de France
plus les autres professions juridiques
il faut que concernant la profession
d'avocat le gouvernement renonce on
n'est pas opposé à l'éventuelle
évolution mais je vous rappelle que la
profession d'avocats du profession
libérale qui est totalement ouverte à la
concurrence donc on nous fait un faux
procès
on butait mais il faut sauter le
gouvernement et la volonté n'ont pas de
vouloir passer en force et en réalité ce
projet loi est un alibi du gouvernement
pour répondre aux critiques certes
justifiées de la Commission européenne
mardi soir la mère du 1er militaire tué
par Mohammed Merah Toulouse Latifa Ibn
était présente à l'université interagge
pour échanger autour de cette thématique
vivre ensemble à l'heure des conflits
acceptons nos différences en confortant
le lien social et l'auteur de mort pour
la France elle a engagé maintenant un
combat contre l'extrémisme après la
disparition de son fils Yolaine Torres
la rencontrer on ne peut pas pardonner
quelqu'un qui prend l'avis de votre
propre fils mais j'ai pardonné la vie
qu'il avait parce qu'il avait pas d'une
famille pour l'éduquer il avait pas un
homme bon entourage c'est un jeune qui
était livré lui-même qu'il était en
délinquant qui le fait de prison qu'il
était livrait lui-même il avait pas
trouvé je pense de l'aide de l'aide de
l'écoute une main tendue c'est ce
qu'apporte Latifa benzetten aux jeunes
tenté par le terrorisme depuis le drame
qui a touché son fils mort sous les
balles de Mohamed Merah en mars 2012
elle mène un combat contre les dérives
extrémistes une association
pour la jeunesse et pour la et un livre
mort pour la France hier soir à
Versailles elle est venue témoigner la
plupart des jeunes qui sont partis c'est
des enfants qui sont fragiles très
fragiles qui manque d'éducation qui
manque
une autorité
encadrement familial mais j'ai jamais
rencontré un enfant qui est bien réussi
et qu'il est bien élevé et qui va partir
en jihad je ne pense pas si je c'est
l'ignorance et connaissent pas le
rhodontité les commercial Islam qui
connaissent rien dans l'islam que leurs
parents ils souffrent il y a beaucoup de
choses comme ça qu'on que je côtoie tous
les jours des parents qui appellent au
secours
à ses parents elle leur demande
d'essayer d'être plus proche de leur
enfant de leur donner de l'amour pour
éviter d'autres moi-même Merah c'est pas
l'état qui va nous indiquer nos enfants
c'est pas la rue qui va dire que nos
enfants c'est pas l'école non plus
l'école elle est là pour faire l'avenir
à nos enfants on apprend l'éducation à
l'école une partie mais la grande partie
c'est les parents qui sont responsables
à l'initiative du groupe interreligieux
pour la paix des Yvelines la conférence
était intitulée vivre ensemble à leur
des conflits Samuel Sandler chenaisien
dont le fils et les deux petits enfants
ont aussi été assassinés par Mohamed
Merah était dans la salle pour soutenir
le témoignage s'il fait confiance au
politique quant aux mesures à prendre
pour éviter d'autres drames il craint ce
phénomène des jeunes endoctrinés qui
partent faire le jihad en Syrie cette
même processus que veut qu'on fait les
nazis pendant la guerre
donc c'était la propagande nazie et
ensuite on a vu où ça mener
malheureusement je crois que c'est pire
que les nazis parce que eux sont fiers
de leurs actes les nazis se cachaient
latifa benzetten ne s'arrête pas là
vendredi elle sera devant les collégiens
de l'établissement Le Corbusier à Poissy
pour échanger avec eux
tout de suite sur TVfil le 7 8 week-end
vos idées loisirs sortis pour les
prochains jours lundi pour le journal à
18h vous retrouverez Catherine sulato
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
des samedi pour café politique nouveau
numéro avec Bertrand Houillon mer
socialiste de Magny-les-Hameaux il a
grandi dans cette ville avant d'en
prendre la tête pour la première fois en
2012 puis d'être élu en 2014 son
parcours mais aussi ses projets mais il
est à vous manileamo une ville à la
campagne qui doit répondre entre autres
aux enjeux de l'urbanisme n'oubliez pas
aussi notre site internet pour voir
toutes nos émissions grâce au replay
tous les reportages également et puis
vous pouvez nous suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux excellent weekend